what's up Wolfgang a lot of you have
been asking me recently about Joe and
Anthony Russo's comments on the death of
Drax the destroyer 's family for those
of you who are not aware this was
revealed to us due to commentary on
Avengers infinity war from the directors
themselves Joe and Anthony Russo just a
reminder that the Avengers infinity war
blu-ray giveaway is still going on so if
you haven't had a chance to get your
hands on the digital copy or you would
like a blu-ray copy for yourself enter
my giveaway all you have to do to enter
is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero so ever since
Infinity Ward came out on digital
release and the commentary has been
released with that we've been learning
just a ton of information from the
directors the writers the producers etc
and it's been awesome because we're
getting an insight to things that we
really didn't know before one of those
things was how Drax is family was killed
if you've been following the guardians
of the galaxy since their first movie
you know that Thanos killed
Drax his daughter and wife ever since
then Drax the destroyer has been hungry
for revenge dude how long have you been
standing there an hour
I'm sure that's us hi Drax
in the commentary track for infinity war
the Russo brothers talked about the
scene in nowhere where the Guardian see
Thanos for the first time this is the
first time that we actually see Drax
attempt his revenge on Thanos I know you
have the reality stone towards the
recent brothers reveal that this scene
for Drax has a completely different
meaning than it does for the other
guardians of the galaxy for Drax this
goes deeper because it brings back the
memories of how his family was murdered
by Thanos during this scene the Russo
brothers say this is a callback to Drax
is history with Thanos here his planet
was treated the same way as gamora's
planet Drax was put on one side his
family was put on the other in infinity
war we see the flashback scene with
Gamora and her home planet in this scene
Thanos is on gomorrah's home planet
doing his mission of wiping out half of
the universe to save the other half he
lines up half of the population on one
side and half of the population on the
other side and then kills one of the
sides
unfortunately for Gamora her parents
were on the side that was killed and now
thanks to the Russo brothers commentary
we know that this happened for Drax as
well Dano stopped on Drax his home
planet half of the population was put on
one side half of the population on the
other
Drax got separated from his family got
put on one side and then his family was
put on the other and they happened to be
on the side that was killed and ever
since then Drax has sought revenge on
Thanos
he pays for the deaths of my wife and
daughter all of the guardians of the
galaxy have a super close and personal
bond with each other
quill states in the first movie that
it's because they're all losers meaning
they've all lost something or someone
they certainly have all had their fair
share of heartbreak which ultimately
brings them all closer together so that
is how Thanos killed Drax his family
it's important to note that ultimately
Thanos was responsible for this because
it was his order that had them killed
but Ronan the destroyer was the one who
executed the slaughtering but
nonetheless it was Stannis is doing
because it was his personal mission to
wipe out half of the universe
hit me with all your thoughts on this in
the comments below and again another
reminder about our giveaway if you would
like to enter to win a copy of Avengers
infinity war on blu-ray all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
fake wish the Beast
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]